[Music]
what can you guys tell me nobody has
seen this movie what can you tell me if
there's one thing you can tell nothing
because what does where the snitch is
enough snitches end up in ditches and
ditches snitches end up in ditches yeah
there's Italian mobsters say that I
remember who's the one person you can
tell any secrets about this is there
somebody you can find it everybody has
someone they confide my children do you
yeah they know the secrets they're know
all the secrets you trust them well I
trust them that because I said also say
if you tell anybody this school I'm
gonna get fired and there will be no
Christmas parties and so they keep the
secret so you tell no one know how many
superheroes are in this movie don't ask
me I don't know how many trailers were
on set Paul you had a great trail you
don't enjoy trying to be honest in
Congress but we will not have the same
trainers it's a yeah we all have the big
trailer the green eco trailers yes and
then it's just there's so many of us and
then you have to count all of our
doubles it's done
the ad trailers the director trailers we
were proper circus village really yeah
is it true that you were a little
uncomfortable at first yeah playing your
character why I think it was no
physically no I I mean like emotionally
was uncomfortable to join Avengers age
of Ultron is that you lad yeah yeah it
was he was intimidating I thought to try
and carve out your place on screen
alongside really talented people who
have already had you know five years
behind up films of these franchises so
that was you know I know I know it feels
a little bit Paul is it true that Kevin
got teary-eyed when he first saw you
yeah and yet what what happened tell me
what happened on set just to put me on
camera and look at the makeup and the
costume and Kevin Feige was there and he
got kind of teary and and I think this
is it's a it's a lovely thing because
you you you kind of you realize that was
when I really realized that these were
films be made book by fans for fans and
that then that there was there was
something other than he was looking for
something other than just financial
enumeration from these films he really
he really have you digested all the
things that have gone on was not only
black panther but now you are in what
will probably be the biggest film in the
history of the world I'm still digesting
everything or taking everything
in about what's just happened with a
black panther and we're really proud of
it and now to just move into this new
world and have this huge moment happen
where all of the different universe in
the within the universe everybody's you
know sections are kind of being brought
together and tied together and you kind
of have to figure that out and and find
a way to have unity and then help to
bring down a really big villain is
really interesting
[Music]
[Applause]